police say the shots came from one or
more vehicles over 1200 shootings the
city's so far this year it's time for
someone to step up and stop them in
violence
Inglewood is historically one of the
worst neighborhoods in the city of
Chicago and also in the entire United
States of America there have been
children murdered while sleeping in
their beds because bullets penetrated
the walls while they were sleeping
Inglewood is generally a place where no
one feels safe what brought me to the
corner of 75th and Stewart was a young
lady was murdered her name was Lucille
Barnes she was 34 and she was a mother
and she was just trying to break up a
fight and she was killed in a drive-by I
didn't know her but I was outraged and I
felt like at this point if mothers are
being murdered something has to be done
some people thought that it was too
dangerous to go and sit on a corner in a
place where someone had just been
murdered three days before we went out
we put on pink t-shirts and we went and
sat on the corner we got some hot dogs
and we fed people we talked to people
more importantly we gave out a lot of
hugs so we got together these moms who
have the time and who had the passion
for it and I felt that you know being
there and being a president and having
eyes on the street and eyes on the
children that it would interrupt and it
would prevent a lot of stuff that could
potentially happen while you're doing
that you're playing a game with the kids
that you may never get to play with we
want them to grow up together so that
when they're older they're not enemies
and they're not targets of one another
they're not shooting or killing each
other since we posted up on the corner
of 75th and Stewart
there have been no shootings on that
block no shootings no murders there
hasn't even been as much as a fistfight
there's a sense of hope that they didn't
have before it all because were mothers
and you don't want to underestimate the
power of the mother